we've got a whole lot of sexual
confusion in our society we've got chest
feeding
we've got babies drinking human milk
and we have on the economic front
a major she session and the only cure
for a she session you know is a she
covered just ask canadian prime minister
justin trudeau
it is exactly the example of the kinds
of things you need to do to counter the
she
the she session and turn it into a
fact is uh the conservatives don't talk
about that in their lengthy platform
you're you're right justin the
conservatives as far as i know they have
never talked about this she session and
nor have they talked about the
she-covery you got us there
you got us there
so i i thought this was fake when i
first saw the clip i said no this must
be a a deep fake or something like that
no he really said it and the point he's
making
is is even
more ridiculous than the phrases that
he's using
the point he's making is that the
economic recession
has disproportionately put women out of
work
so
the point he's making is that
ultimately we need all the women
to be working
outside of the obviously women are going
to work in whatever they're doing
but we need the women to be working
outside of the home
this is another very radical idea that
was once
only pushed by the left once it was not
pushed by either the left or the right
then it was pushed by the left and then
even the right has adopted it too you
saw president trump talk about this he
said women's unemployment is at an
all-time low
i thought is that
is that a good thing is that necessarily
a good thing is that something we have
to celebrate we insist that all women go
out and work for the widget factory or
something like that
what if a woman wants to stay home what
if a woman wants to raise her family
keep a house and watch the kids
is that that's bad because then because
that would be the she session because
then the women's unemployment rate would
be high i mean they're not actually
unemployed they're doing the most
important work on earth around which all
the other work revolves but
that is not
understood or recognized or valued in
our modern liberal society liberal not
just on the left but on the right as
well
why can't women do that you know there
was a famous debate between the american
feminist betty friedan and the french
feminist simone de beauvoir and betty
friedan said something and i think a lot
of people would agree with she said you
know if women want to go work that's
fine and if women want to stay home with
the kids that's fine too and simone
before said no
no no no
you cannot give women a choice because
if you give women a choice to stay home
and raise the kids they'll take it
and we can't have women taking that
choice because that is not conducive to
liberation
so you've got to force women to go to
work
and then you get into this strange sort
of economy now
where
uh men pay other women to raise their
children so that their wives can go work
for another man and get a paycheck so
that you can pay the babysitter to why
it does it gets a little bit strange
sometimes because women are not really
given the choice they're given sort of
the illusion of that choice but all of
the political forces
all of the cultural forces are telling
women don't if you stay home you're a
loser if you stay home you're wasting
your life and your education all the
that great critical race theory that you
learned in school and all those crazy
gender theories
that's that's an illusion that's an
illusion of choice
pretty strange
pretty strange stuff kind of it's like
we're it's like we're misunderstood it's
like our best impulses are leading us to
misunderstand certain things
i'm glad you like that clip you can get
the whole show on apple podcasts spotify
google play stitcher for free it's the
michael knowles show type it in search
it in right now in your podcast app
subscribe
maybe leave a five-star review i don't
know i really appreciate it helps us get
around some of the big tech censorship
that occasionally exists around here see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]